[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
see which proteins like it hot with new
isothermal applications on uncle i am
kaylee bach of labrutz and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by unchained labs
to learn more visit unchainedlabs.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
andre mueller phd product manager uncle
at unchained labs
dr mueller you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for this
introduction and thank you all for
joining me um this morning for my
presentation that i titled see which
proteins like it hot with the new
isothermal applications in uncle
when you're working with proteins and
you want to test proteins for
electricity
you usually run a thermal ram thermal
ramps are quick about two hours give you
a lot of information about the melting
and the aggregation behavior of the
protein and allow you to narrow the list
of candidates down so you have fewer
candidates to focus your subsequent work
on however long-term exposure is also
something you want to keep in mind
because i'm sure you've all been there i
certainly have living in the bay area
with the proverbial fog you walk out in
the morning oh it's not going to be
sunny today i'm not going to get burned
i don't need sunscreen and then in the
evening everything is red long-term
exposure is something to to work with
something to think about something to be
aware of and sunscreen helps and in the
same vein looking at the isothermal
stability of a protein can help you
prevent
bad surprises later on in the
development process when we are talking
about isothermal stability of proteins
what we want to look at really is we
keep our proteins at a steady
temperature over a long period of time
and we monitor their behavior their
unfolding behavior the aggregation
behavior and that's things that you can
do with the new isothermal applications
in uncle
why is this important well you know
what people oftentimes do in developing
a protein candidate further is they do a
thermal ram first to narrow down the
number of candidates and then they do
the isothermal testing at the very end
of the development process that's
because isothermal as it is oftentimes
done is pretty cumbersome you have to
have a large amount of protein solution
you have to store it you have to run it
for example an hplc to look at
aggregation and loss due to aggregation
and all these things make isothermal
testing make long-term storage testing
kind of cumbersome
even accelerated stability testing is
not really that super fast it still
takes a considerable amount of time and
also of volume
when using the new isothermal
applications in uncle we open a door to
testing
both thermal ramping behavior and
isothermal long-term behavior at the
same
stage of the candidate selection process
so early on it is so easy to run
isothermal angle you can run between 1
and 48 samples at a time so that you can
use both thermal ramping experiments and
isothermal long-term storage experiments
to narrow down your list of candidates
and i think that's really the power of
it that you get access to this very
important metric of your protein early
on and what i will talk about in this uh
presentation i'll give you two
case studies where we looked at two
proteins and compare results we have
from thermal ramps with results we have
from longer term isothermal exposures
before talking about that let me first
briefly review what we mean when we talk
about protein stability proteins of
course we all know they have a native
structure they have a native fold and
that's in an equilibrium with the
unfolded state so by increasing the
temperature you can push this
equilibrium towards the unfolded state
this is what we refer to as
conformational stability of a protein to
make things more complicated proteins
also do other things they can also
aggregate something that we call the
colloidal stability and both the native
state can aggregate and the unfolded
state can navigate so in order to
monitor the behavior of protein to
monitor protein behavior protein
stability over time or over temperature
we want to keep both the conformational
and the colloidal stability
in mind we want to keep an eye on both
of these and the right tool for the job
to do this is uncle uncle combines three
different measurement modalities in one
instrument so we can measure
fluorescence we can measure static light
scattering and we can measure dynamic
light scattering in a temperature
controlled environment
in terms of the fluorescence we use two
different laser systems to excite
fluorescence we use a uv laser of 266
nanometers and we use a blue laser of
473 that way we can excite both the
protein intrinsic fluorescence with the
uv laser and potential dyes that you
want to use that's the blue that's what
the blue laser is for at the same time
as exciting with two laser systems we
monitor the full spectrum of
fluorescence emission of the analyte so
we are very flexible in looking at the
protein in the shorter wavelengths or
reporter dyes like cipro orange and the
longer wavelengths in the two
case studies i'll show later we'll have
we will cover both of these topics as
well
the
signals that or the light that is
scattered from those two lasers is what
we use in our sls experiment static
light scattering is a readout of molar
mass as a protein aggregates the molar
mass increases so the sls signal is
something we can use to assess protein
aggregation
over time or over a temperature gradient
we have that sls data for both of our
lasers so both the uv laser and the blue
laser that gives us a very high
sensitivity of detection of aggregation
and at the same time gives us a big
dynamic range so we can cover
orders of magnitude of aggregation
occurring
uncle also packs dynamic light
scattering it sounds almost like static
light scattering but is fundamentally
different here in this case we look at
the diffusive behavior of our analyte
and that is an orthogonal measure of
aggregation that um you can can apply
um temperature control uncle can be set
in temperature between 15 degrees
celsius and 95 degrees and we can do
that for a ramp but we can also of
course do this for isothermal
experiments and keep the temperature
steady over longer periods of time
the heart of uncle the sample
introduction to uncle happens in the
unis the unis are arrays of 16 quarts
cuvettes in an anodized aluminium frame
that anodized aluminium is there to make
sure that the temperature conductance is
high so the temperature of the sample is
what you've actually said and these
cuvettes have a volume of nine
microliters they're open on both ends
fairly easy to load capillary
force sucks the sample right in and then
these unis are clamped in the blue
uniframe with silicone seal so these
silicon seals are consumables and they
seal off the quartz cuvette and you
don't have to worry about the
evaporation the nine microliters of your
sample are safely sealed in the uni and
then you can use that as um
in your temperature ramp or also in your
isothermal experiment
when you run a protein in a thermal ramp
so in this case here you see individual
spectra building up and we have one
spectrum recorded for every degree in
our temperature ramp from 15 to 95 so 80
spec right here in this case and what
we're seeing as this temperature
increases is that the protein unfolds
and you see that the fluorescence
spectrum changes the maximum first of
all gets lower and it shifts to the
right it shifts to longer wavelengths
for this protein
that is because the
aromatic amino acid residues that are
responsible for the autofluorescence of
the protein the phenylalanines tyrosines
tryptophans are usually buried on the
inside of the protein in a hydrophobic
environment and they show fluorescence
as the protein melds and they are turned
outside to the hydrophilic environment
that the protein is in um their
fluorescence behavior changes and when
we monitor the fluorescence in the
temperature gradient we can assess
unfolding that way this full just
shows also the full spectrum of
fluorescence of uncle so we record from
250 to 720 nanometers i cut this off a
little bit here because it's just the
baseline but um you can look at the
protein intrinsic fluorescence here in
the blue section if you had a die in
here you would see that over here and i
have an example for that coming up later
this is the raw data that uncle delivers
so the spectra and then we process that
data to a graph that looks something
like this we have our fluorescence here
on the left y-axis the x-axis is the
temperature this is a temperature ramp
experiment and we have our static light
scattering in green on our right
y-axis here in this case what we're
showing for fluorescence is what we call
the bcm the barycentric mean that is the
spectral center of gravity of our
fluorescence emission it is the
wavelength that separates the area under
the curve into equal halves
we
with this kind of analysis we integrate
over the entire peak of the fluorescence
emission so about 130 wavelengths which
gives us a really high signal
to noise ratio and a calm signal so if
we follow this we can see how as the
fluorescence emission maximum shifts in
wavelengths we see that uh represented
here in the curve and then there are two
inflection points in this curve which
the software determines by looking at
the differential those would be the two
melting curves uh there's two melting
points sorry tm1 and tm2 of our analyte
that is what we want to find out in our
temperature ramp
at the same time is looking at the
unfolding behavior we also get a glance
on the colloidal stability because the
static light scattering signal is rather
boring it's rather flat and then at
around 80 degrees that starts spiking
because that's when
the sample starts aggregating this
aggregation for this specific sample
here happens in concert with the tm2
with the second melting event
so so much to introduction so much as to
the theory of what we find out in a
temperature ramp let's take a look at
the first case study in this case we
have a monoclonal antibody commercially
available monoclonal antibody in three
different formulations three different
formulations we have the uh no salt
condition in green we have low salt 15
millimolar sodium chloride in blue and
we have high salt 250 millimolar sodium
chloride in yellow otherwise the buffer
that the system is the buffer system is
a 25 millimolar histidine buffer of ph
7.4
so when we look at these three uh
formulations that are varying only in
their salt content we and we look at the
melting behavior these three
formulations show pretty much
comparable similar melting behavior so
it's varying melting points may vary
between 69.5 and 70.4 degrees celsius so
about one degree difference the high
salt condition in yellow seems to be
slightly less stable than the no salt
and the low salt condition
when we look at the
aggregation behavior and i forgot to
mention this earlier but we measure
these two parameters at the same time in
the same volume so the sample is in the
uni and we record static light
scattering and fluorescence
concomitantly same time same sample same
temperature
point in this gradient
looking at the aggregation behavior we
can see that the low salt in
blue let me put the arrows in for the
actual aggregation points um so the um
the low salt condition 50 millimolar
starts aggregating first and um the no
salt and high salt conditions they start
aggregating a little bit later um these
two uh aggregation points are about one
degree different this one is 66 degrees
so this about seven degrees lower so
there's significant destabilization in
terms of aggregation of our sample in
the low salt condition but um
differentiating between the no salt and
the high salt is going to be difficult
that's what we can learn from the
temperature gradient as i was mentioning
earlier we also measure dls so let's
take a look at what that shows and our
dls experiment actually confirms that
the sample aggregates in our thermal
ramp when we look at the dls spectra
that were recorded or the signal i
should say that's not a spectrum at 15
degrees we see that the
monoclonal antibody shows a typical
diameter of about 10 11 nanometers
and then as we have ramped the
temperature up in 95 you can see that
these
diameters have increased to more than a
micrometer so dls confirms that our
sample has aggregated
and confirms what we saw from the static
light scattering signal
now what can we learn about our
monoclonal antibody in an isothermal
experiment so in this case we have our
monoclonal antibody we incubate it at a
given temperature over long periods of
time and we see how our fluorescence and
our um our static eye scattering signal
will change you can also look at the
dynamic light scattering signal of
course
example data so this is not quite a case
study yet i'll get to that in a second
but let's look at some example data here
we also see um that look at the
fluorescence in blue on the left y axis
that the bcm value shifts and this is an
isothermal experiment over 24 hours at
58 degrees and at the same time as the
fluorescence signal is monitored and
changes we also monitor the um sorry
same time as the fluorescent signal is
monitored and changes the static light
scattering signal is also monitored and
changes indicating that the sample is
aggregated so again in uncle we measure
fluorescence and static light scatter at
the same time and can
deduce what our sample does in this
isothermal experiment
this experiment was run at 58 degrees
celsius and i think the one of the most
important questions when running an
isothermal experiment is how do you want
to design it how do you want to find how
do you choose which temperature you
incubate in
some people like using
melting temperature minus five degrees
other people use 42 degrees 47 60
degrees because they have an incubator
set at that temperature it's it's really
quite flexible and there is not really
any consensus on how you would want to
do it so for our experiment uh what we
did is we looked at our
melting and aggregation temperatures and
then chose 60 degrees as a temperature
for our isothermal that's about 10
degrees lower than the melting
temperatures and it's about six to eight
degrees lower than what we saw for
aggregation
what i think is really one of the
strengths in uncle is that these
isothermal experiments are so easy so
you could actually run several of them
one day at 60 degrees next day at 65
next day at 55 and really find out what
the ideal
temperature for your isothermal longer
term isothermal is so you do like a
scouting experiment in our case we chose
60 degrees and we actually did see
something so let me show what we found
so looking at the static light
scattering intensity from a monoclonal
antibody and this is one at 266 so using
the uv laser we see that the low salt
condition in blue here 50 millimolar
salt starts aggregating first and
the high salt condition and the no salt
conditions start aggregating later so
until about three hours um there they
behave similarly and then we really see
a difference between the two conditions
so by running a six hour isothermal
experiment at 60 degrees we can really
um show that although the aggregation
temperatures between yellow and green
between high salt and nozzle are only
different by one degree celsius
the aggregation behavior in the
isothermal experiment over six hours
really shows us which is the which to
which the most stable formulation is
as i was mentioning we are not only
measuring um the static guide scattering
at 266 nanometers we're also measuring
at 473 nanometers and that result
confirms what we saw for the short
wavelengths also here the aggregation of
the low salt condition 50 millimolar
salt in blue is occurring first um and
the most stable one is the no salt
condition here in green the new
isothermal applications in uncle also
allow you to determine
rate constants i'm showing this down
here so for the blue condition the low
salt condition that shows the highest
aggregation the k1 the
rate constant is the lowest value so we
also
in addition to looking at the graphs by
i we also have a
mathematical metric
for
the aggregation in in the form of the
rate constants
isothermal experiments like this can
take a lot of time so in this case it
only took six hours but you could in
principle
devise an isothermal that takes several
days takes up to a week and that kind of
sort of locks in your instrument for the
duration of that experiment but because
isothermal testing takes time and
because we know that our samples are
safely sealed in the uni we thought it
might be really nice to have another set
of applications in uncle that we termed
the out of the box apps as the name
suggests you incubate outside of ankle
you take your sample
read the signal dynamic light scattering
static light scattering fluorescence you
take the uni out put it in an external
incubator incubate it there as long as
you like put it back into uncle and add
another data point so the file the
results file is not locked you can add
you can append data points and evaluate
analyze that data
together and
when you have all the data points in
that you would like to have and also
you're not tight in terms of the
temperature the time stamps you can
choose how many hours you want in
between the individual reads what does
this look like in practice in practice
so here is an example of our monoclonal
antibody we measured um static light
scattering at 472 nanometers so
aggregation behavior at time point zero
at 20 hours 40 hours 60 hours and again
we can clearly see that the low salt
condition in blue 50 millimolar salt
shows aggregation that starts sometime
after the 20 hour time point and um we
can grab we can grab that we can we can
measure that with our out of the box
experiment
for the 20 hours between those reads
uncle is free for other things so you
can start an out of the box experiment
for isothermal
take your sample out put it in an
incubator and then use uncle for the
time being for other experiments like a
kd run a b22 measurement or a thermal
ram for other um
researchers or other other projects so
it gives you a lot of flexibility in how
you use your instrument
we can do this otb out of the box
experiment not only for static light
scatter we can also do this for dynamic
light scattering so here included dls in
this daily snapshot
time point zero 10.20 hours 10.40 hours
and we have one light blue sample here
kept at four degrees and you can see the
12 that 12 nanometer diameter of that
igg remains constant in the fridge but
at 60 degrees we see clear clear
increase so this out of the box
experiment gives you a good way of
following the aggregation of your sample
for our
monoclonal antibody here's a summary all
the aggregation metrics agree so if we
look at the aggregation from temperature
ramp versus the ones from the isothermal
experiments and the otb out of the box
we can see that the low salt condition
really is the worst in terms of
aggregation and if you had to choose one
it's probably a 25 millimolar hist in a
ph 7.4 without salt is going to be the
best one that you can look at
that concludes the first case study
let's take a second
case study into account here and that
used rnas a rnas a is a small protein
about 17 kilo dollars and it's very low
in aromatic residues so if we look at
the fluorescence um here is the
monoclonal antibody we just had with the
fluorescence after 266 nanometer
excitation and here's the rnas air you
see it's a much lower fluorescent yield
and if you looked at the bcm curve for
rna it'd be pretty flat it doesn't show
much change because there is just very
few aromatic residues in here that would
be usable in intrinsic protein
fluorescence what do you do in this case
well we can use a reporter die so we
used cipro orange in this case the
orange is a dye that interacts with
hydrophobic protein patches so as the
protein unfolds these hydrophobic
patches are presented cipro interacts
with those and increases its
fluorescence so as you see that here on
the
on the right side if my pointer moves
with me we have the folded protein where
zipper orange has nothing to interact
with so there's very low fluorescence
yield but as the protein unfolds or is
unfolded i should say we see a much
higher fluorescence yield from the cipro
interacting with the hydrophobic patches
of the protein
so when we look at
thermal ramp experiment using rns a and
cipro orange this is what we see with
our three formulations the same
formulations as before we see no
difference in the melting behavior
between those three formulations and we
also don't see any aggregation happen so
in terms of rnas a there's really no way
we can judge which of these formulations
is better and which one is the one we're
going to use for further optimization
studies so what we did is we also took
this analyte here in
an isothermal experiment and what we
actually see here is we see aggregation
that starts around after 10 11 hours
in the no salt condition in green and in
the low sodium blue we can see clear
aggregation occurring this is looking at
the 266 nanometer
light scattering intensity whereas in
high salt it remains uh flat so no
aggregation in high salt aggregation in
no salt and in low cells so in this case
we need the isothermal experiment to
really be able to differentiate between
the different formulations
we also of course wanted to try the new
out-of-the-box app for this um
analyte so this is the static light
scattering we look at the average
diameter over three days measured once a
day and you can see that in the high
salt confirms what we saw from static
light and scattering in high soil it
remains flat whereas in low salt and no
salt here in green and blue we see
significant aggregation that is already
visible almost after the first day
again in otb experiments out of the box
experiments you are flexible in
staggering your data points whatever way
you want the files themselves are time
stamped so the instrument or software
will keep track of the um the time
elapsed but for these
24 hours between those reads you can use
your instrument for other purposes
so summarizing the second case study of
rnasa only the isothermal experiment is
able to rank
the different conditions the ramp
rate doesn't give the ramp doesn't give
us any difference it looks good in all
cases but looking at it isothermally we
can really differentiate between the
formulations and see that only the 250
millimolar salt condition is really good
and something that we want to look into
further for further refinement of our
formulation
so to summarize this uncle the first
all-in-one stability platform has a set
of tailor-made
isothermal stability tools both the
regular isothermal tools and the
out-of-the-box tools that allow you to
use to start using
long-term stability testing early on in
your candidates selection process we of
course retain what we had before the tmt
ag applications we can still run dsf
applications we can also take a look at
viral capsule stability and we also
actually have an isothermal application
that is specifically coined towards
viral vectors
not the topic of this webinar but we'll
talk about this in the future you can
also still use uncle's dls
for a dls with poly dispersity analysis
or combine it with a thermal ramp you
can look at
colloidal stability parameters like kd
v22 the second viral coefficient or g22
you can use uncle to look at thermal
recovery viscosity and also add
isothermal chemical denaturation
experiments
so in
with all this uncle is really your
lifeguard at the beach it'll watch over
your 48 samples for two hours it'll also
look over them for a day or two days and
tell you when it's time to put on
sunscreen uncle is your
all in one protein stability platform
make sure that all of your analytes
behave the way or you know how your
analytes will behave and with that i'm
going to be happy to answer any
questions that have come on thank you
very much
thank you dr mueller for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for
all right so let's get started
our first question asks does uncle have
tools for 21 cfr pt 11 compliance
thank you very much for this question
yes uncle does have tools for 21 cfr
part 11 compliance we have an add-on to
the software that adds an audit trail
and we can also qualify the instrument
so
uncle is ready for 21 cfr part 11
compliance absolutely
wonderful thank you
next question here how flexible are the
new isothermal apps in uncle
thanks for that one um i think they are
flexible on many levels first of all
there is a whole host of different ones
we have three isothermal applications
isothermal the
the most flexible one that allows you to
choose whatever excitation wavelengths
you want to use and what analysis
options and then we have isothermal for
simple orange users and then we have an
isothermal for viral vectors or for
captured characterization and then we
have the two out of the box applications
that are one is um open and you can use
it for whatever analyte you would like
and then one that is tailored to using
uh
to be used with with viral vectors so
it's five applications which is in
itself flexible and then of course each
of them you can use dls and or sls as
you like and then when it comes to the
data analysis
which is something
we will focus on in an upcoming
live demo we have different uh fit
models we can analyze both monophasic
changes by phasic and triphasic so
overall i think we are giving
researchers interested in isothermal
work a whole toolbox
for them to work with and i would
describe it as very flexible
wonderful thank you
next question here asks can you use a
uni for several tests
uh-huh um the
uh uni is our sample holder so it's a
it's a nine microliter
um quartz cuvette it's an array of 16 of
them and the individual quartz covet is
designed for single use so you can of
course use four of those 16 today and
the other 12 tomorrow
but one single cavett is designed for
single use so imagine you're denaturing
a protein in there and then how would
you know if you can wash it all out
again so it would be really hard to keep
those clean afterwards so they're
designed for single use also
they are sealed with silicone gaskets
and we provide
plenty of silicone gaskets with every
set of unis so these are also consumable
so the uncle consumables are the unis
and
you use them
use them once
they are
single use and but you can use different
ones in the sixth in the array of 16 at
different time points for sure
all right thank you
we're getting some great questions in
from our audience so i want to continue
to encourage you to drop those questions
into that q a box there on the left side
of your screen
we'll continue with our next question
here can we use isothermal apps to study
aav and other viral vectors
yes we can we have the
viral vector toolbox in our software
that has apps for viral vector stability
characterization both in thermal rams
and also isothermally so
um i i think i was alluding to it in in
the talk earlier that this is going to
be the topic of an upcoming webinar
and yes there is a specific
isothermal application for viral vectors
and you can monitor the stability of the
capsules in and of itself and you can
also monitor the
loss of payload the genome ejection of
the viral vector over time
great
next question here asks
when would you use reporter dye
thanks for that question
we used in the study with rna we used
cipro
orange the reported dye because there
was very little intrinsic fluorescence
of the protein so that's one condition
in which you would want to use cipro
orange another is if your lab has been
using dsf for a while and
you have some legacy protocols that you
want to continue using and they just
call for a report or die and then i
think the third scenario that i can
think of right now would be
if you had a situation where your buffer
is quenching fluorescence of the protein
so if for example atp is in your buffer
or if you have ascorbic acid present um
if the buffer conditions quench the
intrinsic presence of a protein then
adding a fluorescent dye
can can help and can make the system
measurable so it adds to the flexibility
of the system to be able to use
intrinsic persons and or um director
essence based on the experimental needs
great
well looks like we have time for one
more question here so we'll go ahead and
wrap up with this one are there any
other changes that were introduced in
the new software
yes there are um i i mean i've worked
for it for for a couple of months now
and i really like
using a new software and everybody who
has used uncle software before i think
will will enjoy using um version 6. we
have for example introduced
replicate groups if you're running an
experiment in triplicate the software is
now able to show you the average of the
curves of the three individual
measurements and also show you the
standard deviation right in the graphic
form uh we've also worked on
the colors
the color assignment to samples and make
the ds dls display a little bit
more
condensed a little bit more easy to to
interpret right away so overall i think
we have been listening to what our users
have been asking us for and implemented
a number of changes so it
of course
version 6 packs the new isothermal
applications
but also the overall look and feel of
the software has improved a lot and i
think it's great fun to use it and
i encourage you to try it out and see
for yourself
fantastic well thank you again dr
mueller for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor
unchained labs for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you